good morning John thank you for your pee
video my main problem with it is that
it's very difficult to live up to what a
beautiful thing you did folks over on
the nerdfighteria subreddit have been
having a good old time there's this and
then this what happened and then this is
this for some reason but then also this
oh yeah one of my favorite things about
being alive in the world right now is
that I can Google pretty much anything
and it's there like I'm not gonna like
any of these things up before I say them
and I'm gonna put the pictures that I
find after I film the video show me a
cat and a horse and out with a hat a
balloon ninja I don't know what that is
show me a dog on a bunny that doesn't
sound like it's possible but I bet
somebody figured out how to do it was it
good probably good probably not better
than al with a hat maybe better than
Christmas ferret just throw in the first
result on here no matter what it is
Christmas fair John I recently choose my
house summer to use Google Wi-Fi because
it's a really they're really quite well
done things but you could either get one
or you get three for the price of two
and so I only needed two so I've ended
up with this extra Google home router
thing and honestly I'm a little bit mad
about it like my instinct is to hold on
to this thing like in case my house gets
bigger I guess it's like $100 plus thing
and it's just gonna sit in a closet
somewhere until it becomes obsolete
enough that I feel okay taking it to
Staples to get recycle this is bad it
makes me upset and there's only one
thing to do with it
gotta sell it on Craigslist cuz somebody
wanted a bed with a hammer it would
become garbage see the situation is that
Google mostly destroyed the economic
value in the router by not offering me a
discounted 2-pack but people worked hard
to create that thing there's still value
inside of an idea to honor those
people's hard work yeah even though I
really do want to see what's on the
inside of it and there weren't any
pictures of it on the internet that's
frustrating for me and look it's
probably also frustrating for a lot of
people watching this because I kind of
made a pact with you I went and bought a
hammer for five dollars and did the
whole thing with the dramatic lighting
and then there's like the title of the
video like I feel bad
that's better this is the router that my
Google home system is replacing and it's
a P Oh what is this form factor why make
it like this so that it's impossible for
it to stay up it is always falling up
just the cords on the back of it can't
get over yes I filmed this before I
smashed it so I don't even know how
satisfying it was to destroy that thing
yet but I'm gonna find out look it's
from 2012 it's done with they're going
for like 20 bucks on Amazon right now at
a certain point it just isn't worth it
for me to stick something on Craigslist
have somebody weird come to my house and
get a router meet me in the target
parking lot who can compete with the
convenience of Amazon dftba.com your
friendly neighborhood a tailor serving
now McElroy merch and also the
baby-sitters club club the best and all
of the baby-sitters club podcast
speaking of dftba.com let's throw up
that weird pee shirt alright John see
you on Tuesday
am I gonna eat the whole donut no I'm
not I'm a 38 year old man I'm not gonna
eat a rusty hammer donut okay bye